>> Stephanie Merry:
Good morning.
I'm Stephanie Merry,
the Book World editor
at "The Washington Post,"
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First, a word of thanks to the
Co-Chairman of the Festival,
David Rubenstein, and the
other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for your questions
and I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you will be
included in the video recording
of this event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
Our guest this morning, as you
all know, is David Ignatius,
a columnist for "The
Washington Post"
who keeps plenty busy writing
smart commentary about politics
and foreign affairs but
somehow manages to also squeeze
in a career as a novelist.
His most recent espionage
thriller, "The Quantum Spy,"
is his tenth novel and it's
an artful blend of science
and subterfuge that follows
the race between China
and the United States to build
the first quantum computer.
And I learned so much
about quantum computing
reading your book.
I didn't know anything about
it and I'd love to hear sort
of your background, your
fascination with the subject
and when you realized that
it would make a good subject
for a novel.
>> David Ignatius: Let me start
by quoting Richard Feynman,
the Nobel Prize winning
physicist who said,
"If you think you
understand quantum mechanics,
you don't understand
quantum mechanics."
And I fear that that is true
with my own non-technologist
understanding
of this fascinating
but complicated area.
I'll talk about it in a
minute but I just have to say
to this audience, this
is a thrill for me
because the person interviewing
me, Stephanie Merry,
my colleague at "The Washington
Post," is the daughter of one
of my wife's and my closest
friends who I've known
since I started as a
journalist in the mid 1970s.
We covered labor together at
"The Wall Street Journal."
His name is Bob Merry.
He's a distinguished biographer,
so to have Bob's daughter Steph,
a great movie critic and now
book editor, interviewing me is
like that's as cool as it gets.
So, thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Merry: Thank you.
Thanks. Yes.
It's a thrill for me too.
He came to my creating
write class in high school
and I asked all the questions
and so now here we are.
>> David Ignatius: You
didn't ask me in high school
about quantum computing.
So I'm going to give
the one-minute version.
Every computer that we have
ever used is what we know call a
classical computer and
that it's made up of bits
that are either zero or one.
They're on or off
and that's the symbol
with those simple logic gates.
A quantum computer, if it
could be built and you have
to always add that, would be
made up of qubits, quantum bits,
that would be, strange
as it sounds,
zero and one at the same time.
They'd be in that quantum state.
People often liken it to
coin that you're flipping,
which is both heads and tails as
it spins and it only becomes one
or the other when it lands.
And as we know from
our, you know,
high school physics classes,
it's only when we intervene
and observe that this
quantum state is resolved
in one direction or another.
So qubits that could have
this simultaneity that could
in effect compute in every
direction would be vastly more
powerful than existing
computer architectures.
The world of intelligence
got interested
in quantum computers
back in the 1990s,
when an MIT mathematician named
Peter Shor posited what came
to be called Shor's
algorithm which said
that if a quantum computer could
be built with these properties,
it would be able to factor very
large numbers very quickly.
Basically, encryption involves,
you know, multiplying numbers
to get these enormous
strings of numbers
that to factor them using even
the most powerful classical
supercomputers would take
hundreds of years, centuries,
you know, basically
impossible time
to do it through brute force.
But if you had a quantum
computer, it could be done
in a matter of seconds
or minutes.
That's the power of it.
So, the intelligence world has
been very excited about this
and as I began to read into
it, I realized that we were
in a race with China,
which in this area
of supercomputing is really
working hard to be dominant,
to have the commanding height.
Xi Jinping and his big
party plenum last year,
where he announced that Xi
Jinping thought was now an
official, you know, up
there with Mao Tse-tung,
announced his plan for
China to dominate a series
of technologies by 2025,
2030 and quantum
computing is one of them.
So it's one of those things
like the Manhattan Project
that's sort of a race between us
and other countries that
want to get there first.
The prize for winning that race
is significant and it seemed
like an interesting
background for this novel.
The fun of the novel
I hope is not so much
in the complicated
technology that you sort
of kind of oh yeah, whatever.
If you want to read
more about it, you can.
But in the way in which the
Chinese intelligence officers
are rendered.
In spy fiction, we know
everything about the Russians,
I mean, spy fiction, just
pick up the newspaper.
You can't escape
Russian malign activity.
We know almost nothing
about the Chinese.
There's never been a
[inaudible] like character,
like Carlos who helps us
to see the operating style.
So that was a lot of the
fun of this book for me.
Characters that I hope you'll
come away from most interested
in this novel are the
Chinese intelligence officers,
the head of their
Ministry of State Security,
Li Zian is my fictional
character and a young officer
who works for him who
I call Carlos Wang.
And then also you'll be
interested in the hero
of this novel who's a
Chinese-American CIA officer.
CIA as we know is a modern
diverse workforce today run
by a woman.
Gina Haspel is now the first
woman director of the CIA.
But there are a lot of people
from all the different
ethnic groups in the agency
who sometimes feel
that they're seen
through their ethnicity rather
than as simply as officers.
And that's what happens
to Harris Chang is
he's manipulated first
by his own colleagues and then
by the Chinese who see him first
of all in terms of his ethnic
identity and it makes him mad
and so the novel is the story
of how that anger begins
to play itself out as he's
dealing with this puzzle
of Chinese attempts to steal
our quantum computing secrets.
>> Stephanie Merry:
And Harris Chang is
such an interesting character.
As you were mentioning, he's
American of Chinese descent.
The Chinese kind of
see him as a traitor
to his people even though
he doesn't see himself,
you know, as Chinese primarily.
But I kept thinking how it was
interesting it added this new
layer to the novel
that wouldn't be there
if he looked like say Jack Ryan.
So can you talk a
little bit about coming
up with this character
and why you felt
like it was important
to the story?
>> David Ignatius: So I've been
interested since the beginning
of my career as a
spy novelist in 1987
and how the CIA really
works as opposed
to these fanciful
descriptions that you often read
in spy fiction and
in particular the way
in which this more diverse
workforce interacts.
The Chinese in their recruitment
efforts historically have played
heavily on ethnicity
and loyalty.
They've gone to people of
Chinese descent around the world
and said, our poor struggling
country, we're just trying
to become wealthy enough
to support our people
and we just need a little help
and this and this and this.
And it often is a very
powerful recruitment pitch
because you're just helping a
little and they just need help
with this particular thing.
There's a moment in this book
where the Chinese intelligence
service is really trying
to squeeze and pitch
Harris Chang in which they
through meticulous research
show him pictures of the village
in Southern China where
his family came from.
His family came in
the 19th century,
worked on the railroads,
as so many Chinese-Americans
families did
and they've got the
pay slips and they know
where the great-grandfather
worked
and they know what
happened to him
and they know here's
somebody from your village
and it looks just like
one of Harris' relatives.
And it's an attempt -- And
they know a lot of other things
about his family that
are but I won't go
into because they're
more central to the plot.
And it has a powerful effect on
Harris Chang but he rejects it.
He's a CIA officer and his
problem in this book is
that his insistence
that he is a loyal,
committed CIA officer isn't
believed by his colleagues.
And they begin to
doubt him and think
that he's been compromised.
And I think that that --
There's some real life stories
if you follow this literature.
Wen Ho Lee is an example
[inaudible] Los Alamos
where this issue is played out.
You also will know if you've
been reading the newspapers
that, you know, in the months
since this book was published,
two interesting things happened.
One is the Chinese
commitment to beat us
in quantum computing is now,
you know, front page news
on "The Wall Street Journal."
Believe it or not, it's
terrifying to think of,
a quantum computing
caucus in the Congress.
If there's one thing that could
really mess us up, that's it.
And there also was the
indictment and arrest
of a Chinese-American accused
of trying to steal technology,
Chinese-American CIA officer
who like Harris Chang,
served in the Army, who was
accused of trying to steal
and betray big secrets
and that's just happened.
So, you know, this is
fiction imitating life
imitating fiction.
>> Stephanie Merry: And
it's not the first time.
I remember with "The Director,"
you were writing "The Director"
in a character that was
much like Edward Snowden
and then Edward Snowden
appeared, right?
So you've been fairly
prescient with these novels.
Is it important to be
topical with these?
>> David Ignatius:
So, Stephanie,
the joy of writing fiction
for me is playing in the world
of fact which I explore every
twice a week in my columns
against the canvas of fiction
where you can let ideas develop,
give them a richness,
obviously go beyond 750 words,
thank goodness.
And to think when I begin
a novel, I think two years
from now when people are
reading this book, what's going
to seem interesting to them
because you have to sort
of guess, you know, what down
the road will be of interest.
And I did feel -- I was
starting the book actually,
Edward Snowden, I was finishing
that novel when the Snowden,
you know, appeared with all
of his secrets and I thought,
oh my gosh, real life is
so much more interesting
than the book I wrote.
Let me, you know, madly
scramble to try to do it
in a way that's more interesting
and that gets the way
in which the Russians
might've been involved
in this Wikileaks underground
as we read increasingly it seems
to have been the case.
Madly rewrote the first draft
that I'd written of this novel,
showed it to my wife, Eve,
who's sitting in the second row,
you know, just wanting so much
for her to say, oh, David,
you know, it's so much better.
And Eve, thank goodness, said,
I don't think it's there yet.
And I always say, you know,
that is the greatest gift
that anybody can give
a writer is, you know,
the person whose judgment
you trust, you know,
person you most want approval
from withholds it and says,
you can do better than this.
So I thought, you know,
you're right, Eve.
Here's the book I
wish I had written.
I only have six weeks left.
And she said, well,
write that book.
[inaudible].
So I did madly and that
ended up being a book
that looks prescient but it was
because of a desperate last
minute attempt to make it fit
with what we were understanding
in the real world was happening.
>> Stephanie Merry: And
touching on this sort of fact
and fiction blend, there are a
number of moments in the novel
when one character
says, everyone's worried
about the Russians but we
should really be worrying
about the Chinese.
And there were a couple
of times where I thought,
is this repartee or is
this David Ignatius trying
to tell me something.
And I wonder if you
are kind of, you know,
delivering messages here.
>> David Ignatius: Well, I'm
trying to capture what's real
in my fiction but as you know
if you read the recent columns
of mine, just in early
August was with a group
of very senior former
government officials listening
to the top technologists
in our country
at something called the Aspen
Strategy Group that I'm a member
of and I describe this as a
sputnik moment for this group,
former secretaries of state,
former national security
advisors, as they listened
to people say from
the technology sphere,
it's top people who are
speaking off the record,
if you knew what I know, you
would see that in every area
that matters to my company
and to the United States,
the Chinese are ahead of us.
They are prepared to
capture this space.
capture this market segment.
They're just -- And it was
a wakeup for everybody.
Artificial intelligence
in particular is an area
that's going to be so dominant,
you know, I mean I hate
to say it but it's going
to transform every
aspect of our economy.
It's coming at us and
the Chinese for all sorts
of reasons appear to have the
lead in some areas of this
and so, you know, was for
me, it was a wakeup call.
The book is in part about that.
I do think just thinking
about, you know,
Chinese economic
growth, Chinese miracle
which we has been the story of
my, you know, all of our lives,
seeing this country come out
of poverty, become on the way
to being wealthy, on the
way to being our equal.
You know, it's a great story
in a humanitarian sense.
So many people coming
out of terrible poverty
into a good life.
But there is a national security
aspect to this that we do have
to think about and so I'm
trying to do that both
in my fact and fiction.
>> Stephanie Merry:
And you mentioned
that there's a fair amount of
secrecy we don't know a lot
of what's happening behind
the scenes but there were
so many scenes in
the novel, you know,
between the intelligence
officials in China
and the military officials.
And how much of that was just
kind of you had to invent it
out of whole cloth and how much
of it were you able to sort
of research and find out?
>> David Ignatius:
So I researched --
I hate making things
up entirely.
I'm not very good at it.
So it's a fact that Xi Jinping
has over the last five years,
when he's been president
of China,
replaced an entire generation
of leadership in the military,
the party, and, most
interestingly,
the intelligence service
and installed his people.
And he's used what he calls the
discipline inspection commission
as the tool of what is
really a political purge.
So, you know, in the
previous generation,
there wasn't the
Chinese party official,
general intelligence officer
who didn't have something going
on the side, through his
family, through somebody.
The country is just getting
so rich that everybody had
that bank account overseas, that
apartment or home in Vancouver
or Montreal or Australia.
And Xi, through the
discipline inspection process,
began to just use that and fire
people, bring criminal charges,
and as I say, wiped out, there
isn't a senior general left
in the Chinese military who
wasn't hit by this process.
The intelligence service had its
whole leadership team wiped out
and so this novel opens with
Harris Chang, my CIA officer,
using information he has about
a Chinese intelligence officer
who is corrupt, who has been
on the take, and saying,
here it is, here's the file.
Unless you help us do what
we need, this file with end
up with the discipline
inspection commission in a week.
Okay, make up your mind.
And I'm sure that in real life
there have been many similar
situations where
vulnerable military officers,
intelligence officers, you know,
who were, you know, could get,
could be destroyed if some
information were shared
that that vulnerability
has been used.
But it's, you know,
China, Stephanie,
is a country we know still so
little about in these military
and intelligence areas.
The last thing I want to
do is encourage people
to get all hysterical
and oh my gosh, you know.
We just need to be more
realistic as we think
about them, understand,
you know, their ambitions
to be a great power, understand
the particular ways in which
that might be threatening to us,
to understand the many other
ways in which it isn't.
>> Stephanie Merry: In order to
show sort of an authentic story,
it occurred to me that this
took a fair amount of research.
I mean, you were talking
about quantum computing.
You were using Chinese
slang, things like that.
Do you have people sort of
on speed dial that, you know,
you can run pass, like this
is how I'm describing quantum
computing, does this sound
right or how does that work?
>> David Ignatius: So
with each of my books,
I try to assemble
that speed dial list.
In this case when I was
beginning work on the book,
I went to Craig Mundie
who was one
of the most senior
technologists at Microsoft
and I said, Craig, I need help.
Would you introduce me to
the people at Microsoft
who are really thinking
creatively
about quantum computing.
And needless to say, they
had some absolutely brilliant
physicists, a man name Michael
Freedman at the University
of California at Santa Barbara,
a woman named Krysta Svore
who's writing a language
for a quantum computer
that doesn't yet exist.
Their idea of how to
do this is with sort
of braided nano wires that,
you know, encode the qubits
that she's writing, if you could
imagine this, a braided language
that will give instructions,
it's just wow!
So, you know, I spent
time with them.
I went to see a company
in Vancouver
that claims its already
build a quantum computer
that has 200 qubits.
Now I think actually more
than that called D-wave
and saw how they just to say one
more word about the technology.
The problem with these qubits
that can do fabulous
computing is
that they only stay
operational for milliseconds.
And so the enemy of the quantum
computer is what's called
decoherence in which these
qubits just stop having,
they lose their quantum state.
And so you want to keep them
coherent for as long as you can.
Even a brief instant, you
can do an enormous amount
of computing if it's done right.
So these quantum chips are
in cryogenic super-cold
environment,
just above absolute zero.
I went to the lab where D-wave
has its quantum computer.
The guy said -- The founder
of the firm said, David,
I'm going to show you the
coldest place in the universe.
And he meant it.
And he took me to the
refrigeration sort of scheme.
It looks like kind of upside
down ice cream cone on top
of a chip and they bring this
down in stages using chemical
down to literally just
above absolute zero.
I mean, I watched it go
down to like 13 millikelvin,
which is in fact the coldest
place in the universe.
Deep space is about twice that.
And it was just extraordinary
to see, you know,
not just the technology but
the pathways to the technology.
It turns out cryogenics sort of
super-cold environment is useful
in all kinds of computing
applications.
So that's a long answer to
yes, I did a lot of research.
The University of Maryland
has what it hopes will be one
of the world's leading
centers for quantum computing.
I spent a lot of time there.
I spent a lot of
time with [inaudible]
and his program managers
who were talking me
through what they're funding,
what they're not funding,
and when they should decide
to make something classified.
That's another fascinating
puzzle here,
what do you keep open so
the whole world can share it
and work on it together
and what do you bring
in to our veil of secrecy.
So that, you know, for me,
Stephanie, the fun of working
on a book is getting
to do this research.
I love going out and
finding new things.
I, you know, I try to start with
something new with each book
and in the end I did
send each chapter
that I had something really
technical to the person
that helped me and said,
"Am I going to make a fool
out of myself with this?"
And somebody said in a
review, this book is better
than it deserves to be
[audience laughter].
>> Stephanie Merry:
That's a compliment.
>> David Ignatius: It is.
That means it was a close
call [audience laughter].
>> Stephanie Merry: It
sounds like you do as much
if not more research
for your novels
than your journalistic work.
Is that fair to say?
>> David Ignatius: You know, I'm
always doing them both together.
I am not a technologist but
I can see the obvious fact
that technology, the businesses
that surround technology,
the national security
implications
of technology are the
drivers in our world.
And so I need, if I'm going to
pursue the mission that I chose
when I began writing fiction,
to write realistic spy novels,
I've got to understand this
stuff enough to have it
in the background of my novels
because it's in the background
of all the intelligence
work that's done
out there in real life.
And I hope other people making
all of us more comfortable
with the intersection of
traditional espionage and,
you know, the world
of the Internet,
the world of technology,
that's what real life is about
and I hope novelists
will do that.
>> Stephanie Merry: I know
that a lot of people that come
to the Book Festival have,
you know, a novel idea
or a novel draft sitting in
a desk drawer or someplace
and you have managed to make
it work and you're prolific
and I don't even know how
you're able to produce so much.
What's your secret?
Do you have a certain
number of words or hours
that you force yourself
to work on this a day?
>> David Ignatius: So
just to say two things.
I'm sure that what
Stephanie said is right
and that there are many
novelists in the audience.
I think the first thing I say
is we should write fiction
for the pleasure that
we get in writing it
because you never know.
It's such a crap shoot whether
anybody's going to read it
or indeed if it'll
even be published
but I think the pleasure
of inventing this world
in your mind and then
having somebody, you know,
even if it's just a
family member read it,
you know, that's the payoff.
My first novel, "Agents
of Innocence"
which everybody celebrates,
oh my gosh, you know,
I couldn't get that
book published.
I had lived through
something in Beirut.
I had lived through the story
that that book describes,
how the CIA recruited
Arafat's chief of intelligence
and ran him as an American asset
and then how the case
officer [inaudible] was killed
in the American embassy.
I lived through that.
I lived that whole story.
I had published it
on the front page
of "The Wall Street Journal" and
I just I knew so much about it
that I was certain
there was a novel there.
I sent it -- When my
children were young,
I'd go to their schools and
I'd bring along a big book bag
and I'd say, you know, well,
so, you know, I really want
to publish this book and I
sent it to a dozen publishers
which is true and they all
said no and [inaudible], oh,
and then, you know,
and I'd read one
of the rejections
notices, you know.
Dear Mr. Ignatius, you know, how
interesting that you imagined
that you could write a
novel, but we're sorry.
That was, I mean, literally
every publisher in the country.
So kids -- Finally, one
publisher, W. W. Norton,
still my publisher, said
we're not sure we're going
to publish the novel but
we'll give you an advance
against a later work
of nonfiction
and we'll publish
the novel, you know,
to get you to write the
book we do want, not --
So I went back and I rewrote it.
And with that vote
of confidence,
I made it something really good.
So I'll say to the kids,
"so, it was published"
and you know here's the English
and then it got published
in French and then in German
and then in Serbo-Croatian
and then pretty soon there's
this stack of books resting
on the rejection notice and
I think that's the, you know,
if you can finish the book
and stick with it and be lucky
as I was, you'll end
up having a readership.
So long as you just don't count
on that readership being
huge or making much money.
I mean, I'm glad I never
quit my day job because I --
>> Stephanie Merry: So that
aspect of it got easier
in terms of selling the books.
But do you feel like
you've evolved
in certain ways as a novelist?
Has it gotten easier?
>> David Ignatius: It
doesn't really get easier.
What I have realized is that and
this is the genre fiction room,
that it's really important if
you're writing genre fiction,
in my case a spy novel, that you
understand and accept the limits
of that genre, which is to say
that you understand
the expectations
that readers have reading
their book, that they want
to be surprised, confused,
taken on a journey.
They want to feel that they're
in the hands of an author
who knows where the
plot is going even
if the reader's confused.
You need to keep in mind
the experience as a reader,
like what is it that makes
you read on more chapter,
what's that thing that this
kind of book is doing for you.
In some of my earlier
books, I forgot that.
And I didn't stick
closely enough
to the demands of the genre.
I wrote one book that I'm very
proud of called "The Sun King"
and I got a note, Eve has
heard me tell this story
but somebody sent me an email
that said, Dear Mr. Ignatius,
I read your spy novel "Body
of Lies" and on the strength
of that, I bought your
novel "The Sun King."
I want my money back
[audience laughter].
Because it's a novel.
It's not a spy novel.
It's a novel novel.
It's about people
and love and ambition
and kind of self destruction.
It's a novel.
But that's not what it
turned out most people wanted
to read from yours truly.
Okay, I got it.
And since then I've
stuck to my genre.
>> Stephanie Merry: I want to
make sure that we have some time
for questions from the audience.
So if you would like to come up,
we have microphones
here and here.
>> The Chinese supposedly
have a quantum satellite,
do you believe, and
your sources believe it
and how worried should
we be about it?
>> David Ignatius:
So they have --
One of the things the
Chinese are working on very,
very hard is the
ability to, you know,
in effect have quantum
effects at some distance.
And, you know, that
are coordinated.
When you say "quantum
satellite,"
I think that's what
you're referring to.
And I do believe that.
The Chinese also are
said to be experimenting
with what they call
quantum radar
which again uses
quantum properties
and if it's successful
could shred our advantage
in stealth technology which is
really important in our ability
to penetrate and
deliver weapons.
So I take some of that --
Some of the other claims that
they make about their advances
in quantum computing, I think
are hype and I don't think
that they're there yet.
And I should just say, everybody
that I talk to who really knows
about the subject to the point
that they can't tell me
everything they know says the
most sophisticated applications
that will involve decryption,
Shor's algorithm are
the farthest off.
They're a lot of
things that are closer.
Some real close, pattern
recognition, other, you know,
kind of optimization
problems can be done very,
very fast it seems
with quantum computing.
So the -- I think the
concern that I hear is more
about Chinese domination
of AI in part
because the Chinese have access
to so much structured data.
You know, data is what AI
machine learning learns on,
that's the fuel for
the AI machine.
The Chinese have the fuel.
We really don't and
that's one reason
that they have a huge advantage.
Yes?
>> A related question.
A number of people have written
about the existential
threat posed by AI,
including Stephen Hawking.
I have trouble believing this
but would quantum
computing finally make
that a real problem?
>> David Ignatius: Quantum
computing would allow anything
that involves enormous amounts
of computation fast enough
that it would be feasible
where today it isn't feasible
and there's some sublime benign
consequences of that in terms
of drug design, in
terms of simulation,
in terms of material science,
the ability to create
wonderful new things
that will have beneficial
effects for humanity.
So there's a very positive side
that people get enthusiastic
about.
I think the AI worry that
vexes people is when you get
to generalized artificial
intelligence,
machines that really can think,
do they begin to think in ways
that we can't control
or aren't aware of.
Will they explain
themselves to us
as they solve problems
or make decisions?
I mean, transparency of the
AI solutions so you, you know,
the AI system figures
out how to cure a disease
but it doesn't tell
you how it did that.
Is it able to do that?
I think those are
some of the problems
that people are interested in.
You know, to take one
that's fascinated me
that I just reference
in "The Quantum Spy,"
so as you design the
driverless car, how do you deal
with the problem of whether
the car should swerve
to avoid hitting the deer
that's crossing the street
if that will bring
it near a pedestrian
or suppose the driverless car
is approaching an intersection
where on one side
there's a baby carriage
and on the other side
there's a senior citizen.
How is the machine programmed
to deal with that issue?
Well, obviously it's
a nightmare.
You don't want the
programmer to play God
as between the baby
carriage and grandma.
But, you know, those are I
think when people get worried
about an AI world, magnify that
kind of decision, you know,
into national security into
it said that for example
that although we always talk
about having humans in the loop,
that's the phrase
that people use
to reassure themselves
about an AI world.
Well, we'll have
humans in the loop.
Well, that's just not realistic.
You know, in the times that
you'll be reacting to cyber
or other attacks in which
satellites will be disabled,
you know, whole tiers
of satellites
in space will be knocked
out, there won't be time
for a human to make
the decision.
So humans need to be
in the loop right now
as the systems are designed
thinking about the kind
of issues that Hawking raises,
that thoughtful people raise
so that the systems are designed
with the wisest most ethical
guidelines we can have.
But once we're in the world
in which those systems
will be used,
the idea that humans
will intervene I think is
completely unrealistic.
>> I've read and loved
all your spy novels.
Every time I've read one, I've
asked myself, have you worked
in US intelligence for the CIA?
I'm sure you've been
asked this before.
But I don't know the answer.
>> David Ignatius: So that's
an easy one to answer.
The answer is no.
I had been fascinated by this
since I grew up in Washington.
The world of the CIA was all
around in my neighborhood,
you know.
A lot of the parents had
worked for the agency.
So it was like just a
kind of omnipresent thing.
I wanted to be a journalist
from, you know, tenth grade.
I used to sneak into the Howard
Theatre and stayed back stage
and interviewed the
Temptations and Junior Walker.
That's all I was good at.
Happily, it is a violation
of law for the CIA to recruit
or use American journalists
for intelligence purposes
and I think the bright line that
divides the two is appropriate.
I am fascinated by this world
and over many years I
have internalized a lot
of what people think about but
that's an easy one to answer.
>> Hi. I really enjoy
watching you
on Morning Joe a
few times a week.
So I enjoy that.
In the context of what
you're saying about China
and the challenges that
they pose to the US,
could it possibly be one element
of current administration's
let's say, I don't know,
fixation on Russia is perhaps
looking over the horizon
to trying to use
Russia to contain China?
>> David Ignatius: So that's
a fascinating question.
Is Donald Trump in some way
trying to do what Kissinger did,
which was to triangulate these
three powers to, Kissinger
and Nixon in the opening
to China in part wanted
to get leverage against
Russia but at
that time was threatening, is
Trump trying to get leverage
against China that's
potentially threatening
by being friendlier with Russia?
Well, you know, some evidence
that he may have that in mind.
And, you know, I've written
often enough that I think
that -- I write often.
I think the idea of
not talking to Russia,
just being totally
obsessed and crazy
about the subject is a mistake,
that it's important to talk
to adversaries as harmful I
think Russian actions have been,
as destabilizing as they
are for our country.
You know, there's never time
to stop talking to anybody.
So I'm personally
supportive of that.
You know, these larger
issues that I'm going to wait
for Robert Mueller to explain
to me what he could prove
in a legal case as he did in the
indictments, the two indictments
that involve Russian nationals
before I make up my mind
about those ultimate questions
but there sure is a lot
of evidence on its face that the
Russians directly engaged people
in the Trump campaign,
during the campaign to try
to do what our intelligence
agency say was shape the
election in favor of Trump.
The evidence is --
There's stacks of it
and that's already out there.
>> Another quasi-political
question
that I think you'll have
some familiarity with.
In your research for
your book, can you talk
about the difference of the
Chinese central planning system
and their ability to
really direct their assets
versus for example Microsoft or
a private company or something
like that comparing and
contrasting our two systems
and do you think that gives
the Chinese an advantage
or are they going to kind of
fall under their own weight
like Stalin did with
the heavy industry?
What do you think,
thinking ahead two years?
>> David Ignatius: It's a great
question and it's the kind
of classic dilemma
of central planning.
Obviously, there are
advantages of central planning.
The Chinese Academy of
Sciences, the Chinese government
and party structure can direct
effort to these technologies
that thinks they're crucial,
AI and quantum computing are
the most obvious examples,
and make sure that there is
an enormous flow of resources.
The problem is that in doing
that they have to make choices
about which pathways is best
in terms of their funding.
And, you know, direct more to
this single ion trap approach
to isolating qubits
than to this, you know,
Microsoft's braided, what
are they called, fermions,
and who knows what the
right answer to that is.
So a centrally planned system
where somebody's going to try
to pretend they know
the answer may well make
significant mistakes.
In our system over time, you
know, where people experiment,
fail, try again, fail, finally
get it right and the market,
you know, pretty reliably
pushes money toward the people
who have the successful
ideas historically has been
most beneficial.
There are certain advantages
that the Chinese have.
I mentioned the one that
actually worries me the most.
It's weird.
But the ability to have
structured data so that,
they have data on every single
thing that human beings do
because they collect it
about their citizens.
That gives them an enormous
advantage in designing systems
that will have generalized
artificial intelligence.
So, our companies are going to
need to have access to some sort
of structured data in
ways that make us nervous
from a privacy standpoint
but there's got
to be some consortium that helps
them have some raw material
to work with.
I don't know how to do that
but I know people are
thinking hard about it.
I just think it's a
fascinating question,
planning versus un-planning.
>> Stephanie Merry: We have
time for one more question.
>> Yes, thank you for
coming and thank you
for taking my question.
In your book, you
have a character
who was Chinese-American
whose loyalty
to the United States
is questioned.
Over the years, there have been
a number of real-life cases
in which Chinese-Americans
who've worked in the Department
of Energy and other agencies
have had their loyalty
questioned and have been
charged with espionage.
I was wondering if
you researched any
of those real-life cases
and were familiar with them
in building your character?
>> David Ignatius: So
the case of Wen Ho Lee,
who I think you're
referring to, the Department
of Energy employee
who was subjected
to the most intensive
investigation
because people were
convinced, it appears,
wrongly that he had done things
at Los Alamos is the
most obvious case.
There are other cases and
what deeply vexes my hero,
Harris Chang, is that
at the end of the day,
his colleagues do not see
his service to his country.
You know, he's a veteran of the
Iraq War, among other things
so much as the color
of his skin.
It's a classic American problem.
And it haunts Harris and
I'm sure that for Americans
of Chinese descent who have
faced similar questions,
it's a haunting problem.
>> Thank you.
>> Stephanie Merry: David will
be signing books at 1 o'clock.
If you have not read "The
Quantum Spy," you must.
It is on sale here.
David, thank you so much.
>> David Ignatius: Thank
you, Stephanie [applause].
Thanks.